rookie vladimir gutierrez his numbers
from western and southern
well vladimir gutierrez once again a
young player
rookie trying to establish himself in
the big leagues
he went seven innings on 80 pitches
had a no-no going until kevin pallar
spoiled it two-out single in the fifth
way out in front
a dominant at-bat for gutierrez against
hawaii park
well gowdy shows all of his pitches
right there
the change up
but he threw a couple really nice
breaking balls gutierrez hands over the
head the 1-1
that one's sent out
for a base hit
took that off the plate
one two
to center field akiyama
on the back pedal
a couple to two out runners stranded the
reds have been dominant early this
series mitch keller
three and eight record in 13 games
53 punch-outs in 52 and a third here's a
0-2
count coming
and a ball broken back comebacker to
keller tosses to second for one the
first double play boy park took the
throw
again establishing in with the fastball
got a couple weak foul balls and then
gets a little jam shot back at him good
pitch when you can locate that fastball
in the outside corner down around the
knees
always an equalizer not much damage is
going to be done off of that pitch
gets him to chase and keller sent down
the reds in the first now look at
anthony alford
he hit a ton at triple a
at indianapolis hitting 356. oh that is
right off the bat
he's going to have an extra base head
yeah he had two home runs and had two
singles in one inning last night
in des moines and why not get him in the
lineup tonight and sure enough a double
like that
and there he goes fakes he's caught a
run down gutierrez charges at him
mustache is in prime position he gets
the ball
veins feigns flipped to farmer briefs
double gutierrez on the cover he gets
fed in the rundown
bottoms in on it back to farmer
india running in way
and a tumble and bottle with the tag
strike three gutierrez
faces the minimum thanks to one of the
longer rundowns that you'll see i'm
telling you especially as a young player
you
tend to get lost up there sometimes
things happen so fast you have
so many things running through your head
because you want to be good you finally
got your old
there's the pickup from gutierrez
quick feet
from gutierrez now brian reynolds
and a fair ball
[Applause]
hayes will trot in to score and reynolds
will take his place at second oh he's
going to go for third
and reynolds has a triple
the all-star with an rbi with two outs
and two strikes and the bucks on the
board first jesse winker
suffered a broken bat bounced into a
double play
in the opening inning
and he hammers that one down the right
field line kicks off the wall
around third weaker up to second stop
sign for india at third base hakiyama
scores an rbi standing double for jesse
winker another extra base hit tied at
one nick castiano's looking for his
first hit
since he's been back from the injured
list
through the whole basement
india scores winker a later
[Applause]
his first hit since coming back from
injury puts the reds ahead 2-1 the
team's tri-leader at homers
it's outright leader in
rbis joseph daniel bottom
payoff
high in the air left field alford
started in now he retreats winker
measures him up alfred makes the catch
waker breaks from third throw goes to
second winker scores sac fly rbi a team
leading 65th ribby for joey
pitch strike three call beautiful
breaking ball strike three
two k's for gutierrez at fellow pitcher
mitch keller's expense he wants to go
out there and eat innings and get wins
and he strikes out key brian hayes can i
do it john he struck him out yes
i'm excited i think something's fixing
to happen castillanos to right field
polanco back and it's gone
number 19 for nick castellanos
his first since coming back off the
shreve continues to warm for the pirates
strike three call moran down looking six
k's for gutierrez
well we talked about gutierrez
pitching backwards normally you see the
fastball early in the count breaking
ball early finishing with the heater
definitively done you would think after
the inning
sky to left
[Applause]
winker secures it
six strong again
from the man they call goody pirates
shift against winker on the infield
winker
pass the dive of castro barnhart scores
aquino scores
winker wins left on left and beats the
shift a two-run single it's 6-1
and he ropes it
to offer a nice catch by anthony alford
he's done it at the plate and he does it
in left field ending beginning ready to
go now against brian reynolds
reynolds comes up smacks one to deep
center akiyama out of room home run for
reynolds
brian reynolds with home run number 19.
and he's driven in all three tonight
a chance for the reds to tack on a bit
here jonathan india
through the right side base hit
akiyama is waved polanco from right fire
to the plate cut off akiyama slides in
insurance for the reds
three on a jonathan india run scoring
single winker aboard twice each time a
run scoring hit
winker to right field online drive
pauldron
back and forth they go winker's team
leading 23rd home run joey valdo a
single the sac fly he's one for three
joey vano
launch to right center home
run
[Applause]
coming on
the reds blow out the pirates again 11-3
you